[Music]
[Music]
the old appeals to
racial sexual and religious chauvinism
to rabid
nationalist fervor are beginning not to
work
who i am and whether i'm good or bad or
achieving or not all that's learned
along the way just ride
we can change it any time we want it's
only a choice no effort no work no job
no savings of money i realized that i
had the game wrong
[Music]
but the game was to find out what i
already was
uh
so
[Music]
we were saying
how very important it is
to bring about
in the human mind
the radical revolution
the crisis
[Music]
is
a crisis in consciousness
[Music]
a crisis
that
cannot
anymore
accept the old norms
the old
patterns the
ancient traditions
and
considering
what the world is now
with all their misery
conflict
[Music]
destructive brutality
aggression
and so on
man
[Music]
he still as he was
he's still brutal
violent
aggressive
acquisitive
competitive
and
he has built
a society
along these lines
[Music]
so
[Music]
society today is composed of a series of
institutions
from political institutions
legal institutions religious
institutions
to institutions of social class familial
values and occupational specialization
it is obvious the profound influence
these traditionalized structures have in
shaping our understandings and
perspectives
yet of all the social institutions we
are born into directed by and
conditioned upon
there seems to be no system as taken for
granted and misunderstood
as the monetary system
taking on nearly religious proportions
the established monetary institution
exists as one of the most unquestioned
forms of faith there is
how money is created
the policies by which it is governed and
how it truly affects society are
unregistered interests of the great
majority of the population
in a world where one percent of the
population owns 40 percent of the
planet's wealth
in a world where thirty four thousand
children die every single day from
poverty and preventable diseases
and where fifty percent of the world's
population lives on less than two
dollars a day
one thing is clear
something is very wrong
and whether we are aware of it or not
the lifeblood of all of our established
institutions and thus society itself is
money
therefore understanding this institution
of monetary policy is critical to
understanding why our lives are the way
they are
unfortunately economics is often viewed
with confusion and boredom endless
streams of financial jargon coupled with
intimidating mathematics quickly deters
people from attempts at understanding it
however the fact is the complexity
associated with the financial system is
a mere mask
designed to conceal one of the most
socially paralyzing structures humanity
has ever endured
a number of years ago the central bank
of the united states the federal reserve
produced a document entitled modern
money mechanics this publication
detailed the institutionalized practice
of money creation as utilized by the
federal reserve and the web of global
commercial banks it supports on the
opening page the document states its
objective the purpose of this booklet is
to describe the basic process of money
creation in a fractional reserve banking
system
it then proceeds to describe this
fractional reserve process through
various banking terminology
a translation of which goes something
like this
the united states government decides it
needs some money so it calls up the
federal reserve and requests say 10
billion dollars the fed replies saying
sure we'll buy 10 billion in government
bonds from you
so the government takes some pieces of
paper paints some official looking
designs on them and calls them treasury
bonds
then it puts a value on these bonds to
the sum of 10 billion dollars and sends
them over to the fed
in turn the people at the fed draw up a
bunch of impressive pieces of paper
themselves only this time calling them
federal reserve notes also designating a
value of 10 billion dollars to the set
the fed then takes these notes and
trades them for the bonds once this
exchange is complete the government then
takes the 10 billion in federal reserve
notes and deposits it into a bank
account and upon this deposit the paper
notes officially become legal tender
money adding 10 billion to the u.s money
supply
and there it is
10 billion in new money has been created
of course this example is a
generalization for in reality this
transaction would occur electronically
with no paper used at all
in fact only three percent of the us
money supply exists in physical currency
the other 97 essentially exists in
computers alone
now government bonds are by design
instruments of debt and when the fed
purchases these bonds with money it
essentially created out of thin air the
government is actually promising to pay
back that money to the fed
in other words the money was created out
of debt
this mind-numbing paradox of how money
or value can be created out of debt or a
liability will become more clear as we
further this exercise
so the exchange has been made and now 10
billion dollars sits in a commercial
bank account here is where it gets
really interesting for is based on the
fractional reserve practice
that 10 billion deposit instantly
becomes part of the bank's reserves
just as all deposits do
and regarding reserve requirements as
stated in modern money mechanics a bank
must maintain legally required reserves
equal to a prescribed percentage of its
deposits it then quantifies this by
stating under current regulations the
reserve requirement against most
transaction accounts is 10
this means that with a 10 billion
deposit 10 or 1 billion is held as the
required reserve while the other 9
billion is considered an excessive
reserve and can be used as the basis for
new loans
[Music]
now it is logical to assume that this 9
billion is literally coming out of the
existing 10 billion deposit however this
is actually not the case what really
happens is that the 9 billion is simply
created out of thin air on top of the
existing 10 billion deposit this is how
the money supply is expanded
as stated in modern money mechanics of
course they the banks do not really pay
out loans from the money they receive as
deposits if they did this no additional
money would be created what they do when
they make loans is to accept promissory
notes loan contracts in exchange for
credits money to the borrower's
transaction accounts in other words the
9 billion can be created out of nothing
simply because there is a demand for
such a loan and that there is a 10
billion deposit to satisfy the reserve
requirements
now let's assume that somebody walks
into this bank and borrows the newly
available nine billion dollars
they will then most likely take that
money and deposit it into their own bank
account
the process then repeats for that
deposit becomes part of the bank's
reserves 10 is isolated and in turn 90
of the 9 billion or 8.1 billion is now
available as newly created money for
more loans and of course that 8.1 can be
loaned out and redeposited creating an
additional 7.2 billion
to 6.5 billion
to 5.9 billion etc
this deposit money creation loan cycle
can technically go on to infinity the
average mathematical result is that
about 90 billion dollars can be created
on top of the original 10 billion
in other words for every deposit that
ever occurs in the banking system about
nine times that amount can be created
out of thin air
money jitters
ask the obliging bank of america for a
jar of soothing instant money
m-o-n-e-y in the form of a convenient
personal loan
[Applause]
so now that we understand how money is
created by this fractional reserve
banking system a logical yet elusive
question might come to mind what is
actually giving this newly created money
value
the answer
the money that already exists
the new money essentially steals value
from the existing money supply
for the total pool of money is being
increased irrespective to demand for
goods and services and as supply and
demand finds equilibrium prices rise
diminishing the purchasing power of each
individual dollar
this is generally referred to as
inflation and inflation is essentially a
hidden tax on the public
what is the advice that you generally
get and that is inflate the currency
they don't say debase the currency they
don't say devalue the currency they
don't say cheat the people who are saved
they say lower the interest rates the
real deception
is when we distort the value of money
when we create money out of thin air we
have no savings and yet there's
so-called capital so my question boils
down to this how in the world can we
expect to solve the problems of
inflation that is the increase in the
supply money with
more inflation
of course it can't
the fractional reserve system of
monetary expansion is inherently
inflationary for the act of expanding
the money supply without there being a
proportional expansion of goods and
services in the economy we'll always
debase a currency in fact a quick glance
at the historical values of the us
dollar versus the money supply reflects
this point definitively for the inverse
relationship is obvious
1.1913 required 21.60
in 2007 to match value
that is a 96 devaluation since the
federal reserve came into existence
now if this reality of inherent and
perpetual inflation seems absurd and
economically self-defeating
hold that thought
for absurdity is an understatement in
regard to how our financial system
really operates
for in our financial system money is
debt
and debt is money
here is a chart of the u.s money supply
from 1950 to 2006
here's a chart of the us national debt
for the same period
how interesting it is that the trends
are virtually the same
for the more money there is the more
debt there is the more debt there is the
more money there is
to put it a different way every single
dollar in your wallet is owed to
somebody by somebody for remember the
only way the money can come into
existence is from loans therefore if
everyone in the country were able to pay
off all debts including the government
there would not be one dollar in
circulation
in fact the last time in american
history the national debt was completely
paid off was in 1835 after president
andrew jackson shut down the central
bank that preceded the federal reserve
in fact jackson's entire political
platform essentially revolved around his
commitment to shut down the central bank
stating at one point the bold efforts
the present bank has made to control the
government are but premonitions of the
fate that awaits the american people
should they be diluted into a
perpetuation of this institution or the
establishment of another lichen
unfortunately his message was
short-lived and the international
bankers succeeded to install another
central bank in 1913
the federal reserve and as long as this
institution exists
perpetual debt is guaranteed
now
so far we have discussed the reality
that money is created out of debt
through loans these loans are based on a
bank's reserves and reserves are derived
from deposits and through this
fractional reserve system any one
deposit can create nine times its
original value in turn debasing the
existing money supply raising prices in
society
and since all this money is created out
of debt and circulated randomly through
commerce people become detached from
their original debt and a disequilibrium
exists where people are forced to
compete for labor in order to pull
enough money out of the money supply to
cover their costs of living
as dysfunctional and backwards as all of
this might seem there is still one thing
we have emitted from this equation
and it is this element of the structure
which reveals the truly fraudulent
nature of the system itself
the application of interest
when the government borrows money from
the fed or when a person borrows money
from a bank it almost always has to be
paid back with accrued interest
in other words almost every single
dollar that exists must be eventually
returned to a bank with interest paid as
well
but if all money is borrowed from the
central bank
and is expanded by commercial banks
through loans
only what would be referred to as the
principal is being created in the money
supply
so then where is the money to cover all
of the interest that is charged
nowhere
it doesn't exist
the ramifications of this are staggering
for the amount of money owed back to the
banks will always exceed the amount of
money that is available in circulation
this is why inflation is a constant in
the economy for new money is always
needed to help cover the perpetual
deficit built into the system caused by
the need to pay the interest
what this also means is that
mathematically defaults and bankruptcy
are literally built into the system and
there will always be poor pockets of
society that get the short end of the
stick an analogy would be a game of
musical chairs for once the music stops
somebody is left out to dry
and that's the point
it invariably transfers true wealth from
the individual to the banks
for if you are unable to pay for your
mortgage they will take your property
this is particularly enraging when you
realize that not only is such a default
inevitable due to the fractional reserve
practice but also because of the fact
that the money that the bank loaned to
you didn't even legally exist in the
first place
in 1969 there was a minnesota court case
involving a man named jerome daly who
was challenging the foreclosure of his
home by the bank which provided the loan
to purchase it his argument was that the
mortgage contract required both parties
being he and the bank each put up a
legitimate form of property for the
exchange
in legal language this is called
consideration
[Music]
mr daley explained that the money was in
fact not the property of the bank for it
was created out of nothing as soon as
the loan agreement was signed
remember what modern money mechanics
stated about loans what they do when
they make loans is to accept promissory
notes in exchange for credits reserves
are unchanged by the loan transactions
but deposit credits constitute new
additions to the total deposits of the
banking system in other words the money
doesn't come out of their existing
assets the bank is simply inventing it
putting up nothing of its own except for
a theoretical liability on paper
as the court case progressed the bank's
president mr morgan took the stand and
in the judge's personal memorandum he
recalled that the plaintiff banks
president admitted that in combination
with the federal reserve bank did create
the money and credit upon its books by
bookkeeping entry the money and credit
first came into existence when they
created it mr morgan admitted that no
united states law or statute existed
which gave him the right to do this a
lawful consideration must exist and be
tendered to support the known the jury
found that there was no lawful
consideration and i agree
he also poetically added only god can
create something of value out of nothing
and upon this revelation the court
rejected the bank's claim for
foreclosure and daley kept his home
the implications of this court decision
are immense
for every time you borrow money from a
bank whether it is a mortgage loan or a
credit card charge
the money given to you is not only
counterfeit it is an illegitimate form
of consideration
and hence voids the contractor repay for
the bank never had the money as property
to begin with
unfortunately such legal realizations
are suppressed and ignored and the game
of perpetual wealth transfer and
perpetual debt continues
and this brings us to the ultimate
question
why
during the american civil war president
lincoln bypassed the high interest loans
offered by the european banks and
decided to do what the founding fathers
advocated which was to create an
independent and inherently debt-free
currency it was called the greenback
shortly after this measure was taken an
internal document circulated between
private british and american banking
interests stated
slavery is but the owning of labor and
carries with it the care of laborers
while the european plan is that capital
shall control labor by controlling wages
this can be done by controlling the
money it will not do to allow the
greenback as we cannot control that
the fractional reserve policy
perpetrated by the federal reserve which
has spread in practice to the great
majority of banks in the world
is in fact a system of modern slavery
think about it
money is created out of debt
and what do people do when they are in
debt
they submit to employment to pay it off
but if money can only be created out of
loans
how can society ever be debt free
it can't
and that's the point
and it is the fear of losing assets
coupled with the struggle to keep up
with the perpetual debt and inflation
inherent in the system compounded by the
inescapable scarcity within the money
supply itself
created by the interest that can never
be repaid that keeps the wage slave in
line
running on the hamster wheel with
millions of others
in effect powering an empire that truly
benefits only the elite at the top of
the pyramid
four at the end of the day
who are you really working for
the banks
money is created in a bank and
invariably ends up in a bank
they are the true masters along with the
corporations and governments they
support
physical slavery requires people to be
housed and fed
economic slavery requires people to feed
and house
themselves it is one of the most
ingenious scams for social manipulation
ever created and at its core it is an
invisible war against the population
debt is the weapon used to conquer and
enslave societies and interest is its
prime ammunition
and as the majority walks around
oblivious to this reality the banks in
collusion with governments and
corporations continue to perfect and
expand their tactics of economic warfare
spawning new bases
such as the world bank and international
monetary fund
while also inventing a new type of
soldier
the birth of the economic hitman
we economic hitmen really have been the
ones responsible for creating this first
truly global empire and we work many
different ways
but perhaps the most common is that we
will identify a country that has
resources our corporations covet like
oil
and then
arrange a huge loan to that country from
the world bank or one of its sister
organizations but the money never
actually goes to the country instead it
goes to our big corporations to build
infrastructure projects in that country
power plants industrial parks ports
things that benefit a few rich people in
that country in addition to our
corporations
but really don't help the majority of
people at all however those people the
whole country is left holding a huge
debt it's such a big debt they can't be
paid and that's part of the plan that
they can't repay it and so at some point
we economic hit men go back to them and
say listen you lost a lot of money can't
pay your debts so sell your oil real
cheap to our oil companies allow us to
build a military base in your country or
send troops in support of ours to some
place in the world like iraq or vote
with us on the next u.n vote to have
their
electric utility company privatized and
their water and sewage system privatized
and sold to u.s corporations or other
multinational corporations so there's
that whole mushrooming thing and it's so
typical of the way the imf and the world
bank work that you put a country in debt
it's such a big debt it can't pay it and
then you offer to refinance that debt
and pay even more interest
and you demand this quid pro quo which
you call a conditionality or good
governance
which means basically that they've got
to sell off their resources
including many of their social services
their utility companies their school
systems sometimes their their their
penal systems
their insurance systems to foreign
corporations so it's a it's a double
triple quadruple whammy
the president for economic hitman really
began back in the early 50s when
democratically elected mosaddeq who was
elected in iran he was considered to be
the hope for democracy in the middle
east and around the world he was time
magazine's man of the year but
one of the things that he'd run on and
began to implement was the idea that
foreign oil companies needed to pay the
iranian people a lot more for the oil
that they were taking out of iran the
iranian people should benefit from their
own oil
strange policy
we didn't like that of course
but we were afraid to do what we
normally were doing which was to send in
the military instead we sent in one cia
agent kermit roosevelt teddy roosevelt's
relative
and kermit went in with a few million
dollars and was very very effective and
efficient and in a short amount of time
he managed to get
musa deck overthrown
and brought in the shah of iran to
replace him who always was favorable to
oil and it was extremely effective
mobs overflow terran army officers shout
that masadek has surrendered and his
regime as virtual dictator of iran is
ended pictures of the shah paraded
through the streets as sediment reverses
the shaw is welcomed home
so back here in the united states in
washington people looked around and said
wow that was easy and cheap
so this established a whole new way of
manipulating countries of creating
empire the only problem with roosevelt
was that he was a card-carrying cia
agent and it had been caught the
ramifications could have been pretty
serious so very quickly at that point
the decision was made to use private
consultants to to channel the money
through the world bank or the imf or one
of the other such agencies to bring in
people like me who worked for private
companies
so that if we got caught there would be
no governmental ramifications
when arvins became president of
guatemala the country was very much
under the thumbs of united fruit company
the the big international corporations
and our benz ran on the sticker that
said you know we want to get the land
back to the people and once he took
power he was he was implementing
policies that would they would do
exactly that give land rights back to
the people united fruit didn't like that
very much and so they hired a public
relations firm launched a huge campaign
in the united states to convince the
united states people the citizens of the
united states and the press of the
united states and the congress of the
united states that our benz was a soviet
puppet and that if we allowed him to
stay in power the soviets would have a
foothold in this in this hemisphere and
that at that point in time was a huge
fear on everybody's mind the red terror
the communist terror
and so to make a long story short
out of this public relations campaign
came a commitment on the part of the cia
in the military to take this man out and
in fact we did we sent in planes we sent
in we sent in soldiers we said in
jackals we send everything in to take
him out and did take him out and as soon
as he was removed from office
the new guy that took over after him
basically reinstated everything to the
big international corporations including
united fruit
ecuador for many many years had been
ruled by pro-us dictators often
relatively brutal then it was decided
they were going to have a truly
democratic election jaime rodos ran for
office and his main goal he said as
president would be
to make sure that ecuador's resources
were used to help the people
and he won overwhelming by more votes
than anybody would ever win anything in
ecuador
and he began to implement these policies
to make sure that the profits from oil
went to help the people
well we didn't like that in the united
states i was sent down as one of several
economic hit men
to change rolos to corrupt him to bring
him around to let him know you know okay
you know you can get very rich you and
your family if you if you play our game
but if you just if you continue to try
to keep these policies you've promised
uh you you're gonna go
he wouldn't listen
he was assassinated
as soon as the plane crashed the whole
area was cordoned off
the only people allowed in the u.s
military from from a nearby base and
some of the ecuadorian military when an
investigation was launched two of the
key witnesses died in car accidents
before they had a chance to testify a
lot of very very strange things that
went on around the the assassination of
heimi ruledoves i like most
people who've really looked at this case
had absolutely no doubt that it was an
assassination and of course
in my position as an economic hitman i
was always expecting something to happen
to jaime whether it be a coup or
assassination i wasn't sure but that he
would be taken down because he was not
being corrupted he would not allow
himself to be corrupted the way we
wanted to corrupt him
[Music]
omar torijos president of panama was you
know one of my favorite people i really
really liked him he was very charismatic
he was a guy who really wanted to help
his country and when i tried to bribe
him or corrupt him he said look john
he called me juanito he said look
juanito
i don't need the money what i really
need is for my country
to be treated fairly
i need for the united states to repay
the debts that you owe my people for all
the destruction you've done here i need
to be in a position where i can help
other latin american countries win their
independence and and be free of this of
this terrible
presence from the north that you people
are exploiting it so badly
i need to have the panama canal back in
the hands of the panamanian people
that's what i want and so
leave me alone don't you know don't try
to don't try to bribe me it was 1981
and in may jaime rodos was assassinated
and omar was very aware of this torijos
got his family together and he said
i'm probably next
but it's okay
because
i've done what i came here to do i
renegotiated the canal the canal will
now be in our hands he just finished
negotiating the treaty with jimmy carter
[Music]
in june of that same year just a couple
of months later
he also went down in an airplane crash
which there's no question was executed
by cia sponsored jackals
tremendous amount of evidence that was
one of the one of chorizo's security
guards handed him at the last moment as
he was getting on the plane a tape
recorder a small tape recorder that
contained a bomb
[Music]
it is interesting to me how this system
has continued pretty much the same way
for years and years and years except the
economic hitmen have got better and
better and better
then we come up with very recently what
happened in venezuela
in 1998 uber chavez gets elected
president following a long line of
presidents who had been very corrupt and
basically destroyed the economy of the
country and chavez was elected amidst
all that
chavez stood up to the united states
and he's done it primarily demanding
that venezuelan oil
be used to help the venezuelan people
well we didn't like that in the united
states
so in 2002
the coolest stage which is no question
in my mind of most other people's minds
that the cia was behind that coup
the way that that coup was fomented was
very reflective of what kermit roosevelt
had done in iran of paying people to go
out into the streets to riot to protest
to say this chavez is very unpopular
you know if you can get a few thousand
people to do that
television
can make it look like it's the whole
country and things started to mushroom
except in the case of chavez he was
smart enough and the people were so
strongly behind him that
they overcame it
which was a phenomenal moment in the
history of latin america
iraq actually is a perfect example of
the way the whole system works so we
economic hitmen are the first line of
defense we go and we try to corrupt
the governments and get them to accept
these huge loans which we then use as
leverage to basically own them
if we fail as i failed in in panama with
omar to rehost and ecuador with jaime
rodos
men who refuse to be corrupted then the
second line of defense is we send in the
jackals and the jackals either overthrow
governments or they assassinate and once
that happens and a new government comes
in and boy it's going to toe the line
because the new president knows what
will happen if he doesn't
in the case of iraq
both of those things failed economic
hitmen were not able to get through to
saddam hussein we tried very hard we
tried to get him to accept a deal very
similar to what the house of saud had
accepted in saudi arabia but he wouldn't
accept it and so the jackals went in to
take him out they couldn't do it his
security was very good
after all he had one time worked for the
cia he'd been hired to assassinate a
former president of
iraq and failed but he knew the system
so in 91 we send in the troops
and we take out the iraqi military
so we assume at that point that saddam
hussein is going to come around
we could have taken him out of course at
that time but we didn't want him he's
the kind of strong man we like he
controls his people we thought he could
control the kurds and keep the iranians
in their border and keep pumping oil for
us and then once we took out his
military now he's going to come around
so the economic hitman go back in in the
90s without success if they'd had
success he'd still be running the
country we'd be selling him all the
fighter jets he wants and everything
else he wants but they could they didn't
have success the jackals couldn't take
him out again so we sent the military
and once again and this time we did the
complete job and took him out and in the
process created for ourselves some very
very lucrative construction
uh deals we had to reconstruct a country
that we'd essentially destroyed which is
a pretty good deal if you own
construction companies big ones
so you know iraq shows the three stages
the economic hitman failed there the
jackals failed there and as a final
measure the military goes in
and in that way we've really created an
empire but we've done it very very
subtly it's clandestine
all the empires of the past were built
on the military and everybody knew they
were building them so the british knew
they were building it the french the
germans the romans the greeks
and they were proud of it and they
always had some excuse like spreading
civilization spreading some religion
something like that but they they knew
they were doing it
we don't the majority of the people in
the united states have no idea that
we're living off the benefits of the
clandestine empire that today there's
more slavery in the world than ever
before
[Music]
and then you have to ask yourself well
if it's an empire then who's the emperor
obviously
our presidents of the united states are
not emperors an emperor is someone who's
not elected doesn't serve a limited term
and doesn't report to anyone essentially
so you can't classify a president's
that way
but we do have what i consider to be the
equivalent of the emperor and it's what
i call the corporatocracy
the corporatocracy is this group of
individuals who run our biggest
corporations and they really act as the
emperor of this empire
they control
our media either through direct
ownership or advertising they control
most of our
politicians because they finance their
campaigns either through their
corporations or through personal
contributions that come out of the
corporations
they're not elected and they don't serve
a limited term they don't report to
anybody and at the very top of the
corporatocracy you really can't tell
whether a person's working for a private
corporation or the government because
they're always moving back and forth
so you know you've got a guy who one
moment was the president of
a big construction company like
halliburton and in the next moment he's
vice president of the united states or
the president who is in the oil business
and and this is true whether you've got
democrats or republicans in the office
you have to moving back and forth
through the revolving door
and in a way
our government is invisible a lot of the
time and its policies are carried out by
our corporations on one level or another
and then again the policies of the
government are basically
forged
by the corporatocracy and then presented
to the government they become government
policy so it's an incredibly cozy
relationship
this isn't a conspiracy theory type of
thing these people don't have to get
together and plot to do things they all
basically work under one primary
assumption and that is that they must
maximize profits regardless of the
social and environmental costs
this process of manipulation by the
corporatocracy through the use of debt
bribery and political overthrow is
called globalization
just as the federal reserve keeps the
american public in a position of
indentured servitude through perpetual
debt inflation and interest the world
bank and imf serve this role on a global
scale
the basic scam is simple
put a country in debt either by its own
indiscretion or through corrupting the
leader of that country
then impose conditionalities or
structural adjustment policies often
consisting of the following
currency devaluation
when the value of a currency drops so
does everything valued in it this makes
indigenous resources available to
predator countries at a fraction of
their worth
large funding cuts for social programs
these usually include education and
healthcare compromising the well-being
and integrity of the society leaving the
public vulnerable to exploitation
privatization of state-owned enterprises
this means that socially important
systems can be purchased and regulated
by foreign corporations for profit
for example in 1999 the world bank
insisted that the bolivian government
sell the public water system of its
third largest city to a subsidy of the
u.s corporation bechdel
as soon as this occurred water bills for
the already impoverished local residents
skyrocketed
it wasn't until after a full-blown
revolt by the people that the bechtel
contract was nullified
then there is trade liberalization or
the opening up of the economy through
removing any restrictions on foreign
trade this allows for a number of
abusive economic manifestations such as
transnational corporations bringing in
their own mass-produced products
undercutting the indigenous production
and ruining local economies
an example is jamaica
which after accepting loans and
conditionalities from the world bank
lost its largest cash crop markets due
to competition with western imports
today countless farmers are out of work
for they are unable to compete with the
large
corporations another variation is the
creation of numerous seemingly unnoticed
unregulated inhumane sweatshop factories
which take advantage of the imposed
economic hardship
additionally due to production
deregulation environmental destruction
is perpetual as a country's resources
are often exploited by the indifferent
corporations while outputting large
amounts of deliberate pollution
the largest
environmental lawsuit in the history of
the world today is being brought on
behalf of 30 000 ecuadorian amazonian
people
against
texaco which is now owned by chevron so
today it's against chevron but for
activities conducted by texaco
estimated to be more than 18 times what
exxon valdez dumped into the coast of
alaska
in the case of ecuador it wasn't an
accident the oil companies did it
intentionally they knew they were doing
it to save money out there rather than
arranging for a proper disposal
furthermore a cursory glance at the
performance record of the world bank
reveals that the institution which
publicly claims to help poor countries
develop and alleviate poverty has done
nothing but increased poverty and the
wealth gap while corporate profits soar
in 1960 the income gap between the fifth
of the world's people and the richest
countries versus the fifth in the
poorest countries was 30 to 1. by 1998
it was 74 to 1.
while global gnp rose 40 between 1970
and 1985 those in poverty actually
increased by 17
while from 1985 to 2000 those living on
less than one dollar a day increased by
18
even the joint economic committee of the
u.s congress admitted that there is a
mere 40 success rate of all world bank
projects
in the late 1960s the world bank
intervened in ecuador with large loans
during the next 30 years poverty grew
from 50 to 70
under or unemployment grew from 15 to 70
percent
public debt increased from 240 million
to 16 billion
while the share of resources allocated
to the poor went from twenty percent to
six percent
in fact by the year two thousand fifty
percent of ecuador's national budget had
to be allocated for paying its debts
it is important to understand the world
bank is in fact a u.s bank supporting
u.s interests for the united states
holds veto power over decisions as it is
the largest provider of capital and
where did it get this money you guessed
it it made it out of thin air through
the fractional reserve banking system
of the world's top 100 economies as
based on annual gdp
51 are corporations
and 47 of that 51 are u.s based
walmart general motors and exxon are
more economically powerful than saudi
arabia poland norway south africa
finland indonesia and many others
and as protective trade barriers are
broken down currencies tossed together
and manipulated in floating markets and
state economies overturned in favor of
open competition and global capitalism
the empire expands
you get up on
your little 21 inch screen
and how
about america and democracy
there is no america
there is no democracy
there is only
ibm and itt
an at and dupont dao
union carbide
and exxon
those are the nations of the world today
what do you think the russians talk
about in their council's estate karl
marx they get out their linear
programming charts
statistical decision theories minimax
solutions and compute the price cost
probabilities of their transactions and
investments just like we do
we no longer live in a world of nations
and ideologies mr beale
the world is a
college of corporations
inexorably determined by the
immutable bylaws of business
the world
is a business mr bill
the world is being taken over by a
handful of business powers who dominate
the natural resources we need to live
while controlling the money we need to
obtain these resources
the end result will be world monopoly
based not on human life but financial
and corporate power
and as the inequality grows naturally
more and more people are becoming
desperate
so the establishment was forced to come
up with a new way to deal with anyone
who challenges the system
so they gave birth to the terrorist
the term terrorist is an empty
distinction
designed for any person or group who
chooses to challenge the establishment
this isn't to be confused with the
fictional al qaeda which was actually
the name of a computer database for the
u.s supported mujahideen in the 1980s
[Music]
in 2007 the department of defense
received 161.8
billion dollars for the so-called global
war on terrorism
according to the national
counter-terrorism center in 2004 roughly
2 000 people were killed internationally
due to supposed terrorist acts
of that number 70 were american
using this number as a general average
which is extremely generous
it is interesting to note that twice as
many people die from peanut allergies a
year than from terrorist acts
concurrently the leading cause of death
in america is coronary heart disease
killing roughly 450 000 each year
and in 2007 the government's allocation
of funds for research on this issue was
about three billion dollars this means
that the us government in 2007
spent 54 times the amount for preventing
terrorism than it spent for preventing a
disease which kills six thousand and six
hundred times more people annually than
terrorism does
yet as the name terrorism and al qaeda
are arbitrarily stamped on every news
report relating to any action taken
against u.s interests the myth grows
wider in mid-2008 the u.s attorney
general actually proposed that the u.s
congress officially declare war against
the fantasy
not to mention as of july 2008 there are
now over 1 million people currently on
the u.s terrorist watch list
these so-called counter-terrorism
measures of course have nothing to do
with social protection and everything to
do with preserving the establishment
amongst the growing anti-american
sentiment both domestically and
internationally
which is legitimately founded on the
greed-based corporate empire expansion
that is exploiting the world
the true terrorists of our world do not
meet at the docks at midnight
or scream allah akbar before some
violent action
true terrorists of our world wear five
thousand dollar suits and work in the
highest positions of finance
government and business
so
what do we do
how do we stop a system of greed and
corruption that has so much power and
momentum
how do we stop this aberrant group
behavior which feels no compassion for
say the millions slaughtered in iraq and
afghanistan so the corporatocracy can
control energy resources and opium
production for wall street profit
so
oh there's another one
how do we stop a system of greed and
corruption that condemns poor
populations to sweatshop slavery for the
benefit of madison avenue
or that engineers false flag terror
attacks for the sake of manipulation
or that generates built-in modes of
social operation which are inherently
exploitative
or that systematically reduces civil
liberties and violates human rights in
order to protect itself from its own
shortcomings
how do we deal with the numerous covert
institutions such as the council on
foreign relations the trilateral
commission and the bilderberg group and
other undemocratically elected groups
which behind closed doors collude to
control the political financial social
and environmental elements of our lives
in order to find the answer
we must first find the true underlying
cause
for the fact is
the selfish corrupt power and
profit-based groups are not the true
source of the problem
they are symptoms
my name is jacque fresco
i'm an industrial designer
and a social engineer
i'm very much interested in society
and developing a system that might be
sustainable
for all people
first of all the word corruption is a
monetary invention that aberrant
behavior
behavior that's disruptive to the
well-being of people
while you're dealing with
human behavior
and human behavior appears to be
environmentally determined meaning
if you were raised by the seminole
indians as a baby never saw anything
else you'd hold that value system and
this goes for nations
it goes for individuals for families
they try to indoctrinate their children
to their particular faith and their
country
and make them feel like they're part of
that
and they build a society which they call
established
they establish a workable point of view
and tend to perpetuate that
whereas
all societies are really emergent not
established
and so they fight
new ideas that would interfere with the
establishment
governments try to perpetuate that which
keeps them in power
people are not elected to political
office to change things they're put
there to keep things the way they are
so you see the basis of corruption is in
our society let me make it clear all
nations then are basically corrupt
because they tend to uphold existing
institutions i don't mean to uphold or
downgrade all nations but communism
socialism fascism the free enterprise
system and all other subcultures are the
same
they are all basically
corrupt
the most fundamental characteristic of
our social institutions is the necessity
for self-preservation
whether dealing with a corporation a
religion or a government
the foremost interest is to preserve the
institution itself
for instance the last thing an oil
company would ever want is the
utilization of energy that was outside
of its control for it makes that company
less relevant to society
likewise the cold war and the collapse
of the soviet union was in reality a way
to preserve and perpetuate the
established economic and global hegemony
of the united states
similarly religions conditioned people
to feel guilty for natural inclinations
each claiming to offer the only path to
forgiveness and salvation
at the heart of this institutional
self-preservation lies the monetary
system for it is money that provides the
means for power and survival
therefore just as a poor person might be
forced to steal in order to survive it
is a natural inclination to do whatever
is needed to continue an institution's
profitability
this makes it inherently difficult for
profit-based institutions to change for
it puts in jeopardy not only the
survival of large groups of people but
also the coveted materialistic
lifestyles associated with affluence and
power
therefore the paralyzing necessity to
preserve an institution regardless of
its social relevance is largely rooted
in the need for money or profit
what's in it for me that's why people
think
and so if a man makes money selling a
certain product
that's where he's going to fight
the existence of another product that
may threaten his institution
[Music]
therefore people cannot be fair
and people do not trust each other a guy
will come over to you and say i got just
the house you're looking for he's a
salesman when the doctor says i think
your kidney has to come out i don't know
if he's trying to pay off a yacht
whether my kidney has to come out it's
hard in a monetary system to trust
people
if you came into my store and i said
this plant that i've got is pretty good
but the lamp is next door is much better
i wouldn't be in business very long it
wouldn't work if i were ethical it
wouldn't work
so when you say industry cares for
people that's not true they can't afford
to be ethical
so your system is not designed to serve
the well-being of people if you still
don't understand that there would be no
outsourcing of jobs
if they cared about people
industry does not care they only hire
people because it hasn't been automated
yet
so don't talk about decency and ethics
we cannot afford it and remain in
business
it is important to point out that
regardless of the social system whether
fascist socialist capitalist or
communist
the underlying mechanism is still money
labor and competition
communist china is no less capitalistic
than the united states
the only difference is the degree by
which the state intervenes in enterprise
the reality is that monetaryism so to
speak is the true mechanism that guides
the interests of all the countries on
the planet
the most aggressive and hence dominant
variation of this monetaryism is the
free enterprise system the fundamental
perspective as put forth by early free
market economists like adam smith
is that self-interest in competition
leads to social prosperity as the act of
competition creates incentive which
motivates people to persevere
[Music]
however what isn't talked about is how a
competition-based economy invariably
leads to strategic corruption
power and wealth consolidation social
stratification technological paralysis
labor abuse and ultimately a covert form
of government dictatorship by the rich
elite
the word corruption is often defined as
moral perversion if a company dumps
toxic waste into the ocean to save money
most people recognize this as corrupt
behavior
on a more subtle level
when walmart moves into a small town and
forces small businesses to shut down for
they are unable to compete
a grey area emerges
for what exactly is walmart doing wrong
why should they care about mom and pop
organizations they destroy
yet even more subtly when a person gets
fired from their job because a new
machine has been created which can do
the work for less money
people tend to just accept that as the
way it is
not seeing the inherent corrupt
inhumanity of such an action
because the fact is whether it is
dumping toxic waste having a monopoly
enterprise or downsizing the workforce
the motive is the same
profit
they are all different degrees of the
same self-preserving mechanism which
always puts the well-being of people
second to monetary gain
therefore corruption is not some
byproduct of monetaryism
it is the very foundation
and while most people acknowledge this
tendency on one level or another the
majority remains naive as to the broad
ramifications of having such a selfish
mechanism as the guiding mentality in
society
internal documents show that after this
company positively absolutely knew that
they had a medication that was infected
with the aids virus they took the
product off the market in the us and
then they dumped it in france europe
asia and latin america the us government
allowed it to happen the fda allowed
this to happen and now the government is
completely looking the other way
thousands of innocent hemophiliacs have
died from the aids virus this company
knew absolutely that it was infected
with aids they dumped it because they
wanted to turn this disaster into a
profit
so you see you have
built-in corruption
we're all chiseling off each other and
you can't expect decency and that sort
of thing
and feeling that they don't know who to
elect
they think in terms of a democracy which
is not possible in a monetary based
economy
if you have more money to advertise your
position the position you desire in
government
that isn't a democracy it serves those
in positions of differential advantage
so it's always the dictatorship of the
elitist
the financially wealthy
[Music]
it is an interesting observation to note
how seemingly unknown personalities
magically appear on the scene as
presidential candidates
then before you know it somehow you are
left to choose from a small group of
extremely wealthy people who
suspiciously have the same broad social
view
obviously it's a joke
the people placed on the ballot are done
so because they have been pre-decided to
be acceptable by the established
financial powers who actually run the
show
yet many who understand this illusion of
democracy
often think
if only we could just get our honest
ethical politicians in power
then we would be okay
well while this idea of course seems
reasonable in our established oriented
world view
it is unfortunately another fallacy
four when it really comes down to what
is actually important the institution of
politics and thus politicians themselves
have absolutely no true relevance as to
what makes our world and society
function
it's not politicians that can solve
problems they have no technical
capabilities they don't know how to
solve problems even if they were sincere
they don't know how to solve problems
it's the technicians
that produce the desalinization plants
it's the technicians that give you
electricity
that give you motor vehicles that heat
your house and cool it in the summer
time it's technology that solves
problems not politics politics cannot
solve problems because they're not
trained to do so
very few people today stop and consider
what it is that actually improves their
lives
is it money
obviously not one cannot eat money or
stuff money into their car to get it to
run
is it politics
all politicians can do is create laws
establish budgets and declare war
is it religion of course not religion
creates nothing except intangible
emotional solace for those who require
it
the true gift that we as human beings
have
which has been solely responsible for
everything that has improved our lives
is technology
what is technology technology is a
pencil which allows one to solidify
ideas on paper for communication
technology is an automobile which allows
one to travel faster than feet would
allow
technology is a pair of eyeglasses which
enables sight for those who need it
[Music]
applied technology itself is merely an
extension of human attributes which
reduces human effort freeing humans from
a particular chore or problem
imagine what your life would be like
today without a telephone or an oven or
a computer or an airplane
everything in your home which you take
for granted from a doorbell to a table
to a dishwasher is technology generated
from the creative scientific ingenuity
of human technicians
not money politics or religion
these are false institutions
and writing your congressman is
fantastic
they tell you to write your congressman
if you want something done the men in
washington should be at the forefront of
technology the forefront of human
studies the forefront of crime
all the factors that shape human
behavior you don't have to write your
congressmen what kind of people are they
that are that are appointed to do that
job
the future will have great difficulty
and the question that's raised by
politicians
is how much will a project cost
the question is not how much will it
cost
do we have the resources
and we have the resources today to house
everyone build hospitals all over the
world
build schools all over the world the
finest equipment and labs for teaching
and doing medical research
so you see we have all that but we're in
the monetary system and in the monetary
system there's profit
and what is the fundamental mechanism
that drives the profit system besides
self-interest
what is it exactly that maintains that
competitive edge at its core
is it high efficiency and sustainability
no
that isn't part of their design
nothing produced in our profit-based
society is even remotely sustainable or
efficient if it was there wouldn't be a
multi-million dollar a year service
industry for automobiles nor would the
average lifespan for most electronics be
less than three months before they're
obsolete
it abundance
absolutely not abundance as based on the
laws of supply and demand is actually a
negative thing if a diamond company
finds 10 times the usual amount of
diamonds during their mining it means
the supply of diamonds has increased
which means the cost and profit per
diamond drops
the fact is efficiency sustainability
and abundance are enemies of profit
to put it into a word it is the
mechanism of scarcity that increases
profits
what is scarcity based on keeping
products valuable slowing up production
on oil raises the price
maintaining scarcity of diamonds keeps
the price high they burn diamonds at the
kimberley diamond mines they're made of
carbon that keeps the price up
so then what does it mean for society
when scarcity either produced naturally
or through manipulation is a beneficial
condition for industry
[Music]
it means that sustainability and
abundance will never ever occur in a
profit system for it simply goes against
the very nature of the structure
therefore it is impossible to have a
world without war or poverty
it is impossible to continually advance
technology to its most efficient and
productive states
and most dramatically
it is impossible to expect human beings
to behave in truly ethical or decent
ways
people use the word instinct
because they can't account for the
behavior
they sit back and they evaluate with
their lack of knowledge you know and
they say things like
humans are built a certain way greed is
a natural thing and so they've worked
for years on it and it's no more natural
than wearing clothing
what we want to do is to eliminate
the causes of the problems
eliminate the processes
that that produce greed and bigotry and
prejudice
and
people taking advantage of one another
and elitism
eliminating the need for prisons and
welfare we have always had these
problems because we have always lived
within scarcity and barter and monetary
systems
that produce scarcity if you eradicate
the conditions that generate
what you call socially offensive
behavior it does not exist the guy said
well listen that inborn
no it's not there is no human nature
there's human behavior and that's always
been changed throughout history you're
not born with bigotry and greed and
corruption and hatred you you pick that
up within the society
war poverty corruption hunger misery
human suffering will not change in a
monetary system that is there'll be very
little significant change it's going to
take the redesign of our culture our
values and it has to be related to the
carrying capacity of the earth not some
human opinion or some politicians
notions of the way the world ought to be
or some religious notions of the conduct
of human affairs
and that's what the venus project is
about the society that we're about to
talk about is a society that is free
of all the old superstitions
incarceration prisons police cruelty and
law
all laws will disappear and the
professions will disappear that are no
longer valid such as stock brokers
bankers advertising gone
forever
because it's no longer relevant
when we understand that it is technology
devised by human ingenuity which frees
humanity and increases our quality of
life we then realize that the most
important focus we can have is on the
intelligent management of the earth's
resources for it is from these natural
resources we gain the materials to
continue our path of prosperity
understanding this we then see that
money fundamentally exists as a barrier
to these resources for virtually
everything has a financial cost
and why do we need money to obtain these
resources
because of real or assumed scarcity
we don't usually pay for air and tap
water because it is in such high
abundance selling it would be pointless
so then
logically speaking if resources and
technologies applicable to creating
everything in our societies such as
houses cities and transportation
were in high enough abundance there
would be no reason to sell anything
likewise if automation and machinery was
so technologically advanced as to
relieve human beings of labor there
would be no reason to have a job
and with these social aspects taken care
of there would be no reason to have
money at all
so the ultimate question remains
do we on earth have enough resources and
technological understanding to create a
society of such abundance that
everything we have now could be
available without a price tag and
without the need for submission through
employment
yes we do
we have the resources and technology to
enable this at a minimum
along with the ability to raise the
standard of living so high that people
in the future will look back at our
civilization now and gawk at how
primitive and immature our society was
what the venus project proposes is an
entirely different system that's updated
to present-day knowledge
we've never given scientists the problem
of how do you design a society which
would eliminate boring and monotonous
jobs
that would eliminate accidents and
transportation
that would enable people to have a high
standard of living that would eliminate
poisons in our food that give us other
sources of energy that are clean and
efficient we can do that out there
the major difference between a
resource-based economy and a monetary
system is that a resource-based economy
is really concerned with people and
their well-being where a monetary system
has become so distorted that the
concerns of the people are really
secondary if they're there at all the
products that are turned out are for how
much money you can get if there is a
problem in society and you can't earn
money from solving that problem then it
won't be done
the resource-based economy is really not
close to anything that's been tried and
with all our technology today we can
create abundance it could be used to
improve everyone's lifestyle abundance
all over the world if we use our
technology wisely and maintain the
environment
it's a very different system and it's
very hard to talk about because the
public is not that well enough informed
as to the state of technology
at present
we don't have to burn fossil fuels
we don't have to use anything that would
contaminate
the environment there are many sources
of energy available
alternative energy solutions pushed by
the establishment such as hydrogen
biomass and even nuclear are highly
insufficient dangerous and exist only to
perpetuate the profit structure that
industry has created
when we look beyond the propaganda and
self-serving solutions put forth by the
energy companies we find a seemingly
endless stream of clean abundant and
renewable energy for generating power
solar and wind energy are well known to
the public but the true potential of
these mediums remains unexpressed
solar energy derived from the sun has
such abundance that one hour of light at
high noon contains more energy than what
the entire world consumes in a year if
we could capture one hundredth of a
percent of this energy the world would
never have to use oil gas or anything
else
the question then is not availability
but the technology to harness it
and there are many advanced mediums
today which could accomplish just that
if they were not hindered by the need to
compete for market share with the
established energy power structures
then there's wind energy wind energy has
long been denounced as weak and due to
being location driven impractical this
is simply not true the us department of
energy admitted in 2007 that if wind was
fully harvested in just three of
america's 50 states it could power the
entire nation
and then there are the rather unknown
mediums of tidal and wave power
tidal power is derived from tidal shifts
in the ocean installing turbines which
capture this movement generates energy
in the united kingdom 42 sites are
currently noted as available forecasting
that 34
of all the uk's energy could come from
tidal power alone
wave power which extracts energy from
the surface motions of the ocean
is estimated to have a global potential
of up to eighty thousand terawatt hours
a year
this means fifty percent of the entire
planet's energy usage could be produced
from this medium alone
now it is important to point out that
tidal wave solar and wind power requires
virtually no preliminary energy to
harness unlike coal oil gas biomass
hydrogen and all the others
in combination these four mediums alone
if efficiently harnessed through
technology could power the world forever
that being said there happens to be
another form of clean renewable energy
which trumps them all
geothermal power
geothermal energy utilizes what is
called heat mining which through a
simple process using water is able to
generate massive amounts of clean energy
in 2006 an mit report on geothermal
energy found that thirteen thousand
zetta joules of power are currently
available in the earth with the
possibility of two thousand zetta joules
being easily tappable with improved
technology
the total energy consumption of all the
countries on the planet is about half of
a zetta jewel a year this means about 4
000 years of planetary power could be
harnessed in this medium alone
and when we understand that the earth's
heat generation is constantly renewed
this energy is really limitless and
could be used forever
these energy sources are only a few of
the clean renewable mediums available
and as time goes on we will find more
the grand realization is that we have
total energy abundance without the need
for pollution traditional conservation
or in fact a price tag
and what about transportation
the prevailing means of transportation
in our societies is by automobile and
aircraft both of which predominantly
need fossil fuels to run
in the case of the automobile the
battery technology needed to power an
electric car that can go over 100 miles
an hour for over 200 miles on one charge
exists and has existed for many years
however due to battery patents
controlled by the oil industry which
limits their availability to maintain
market share coupled with political
pressure from the energy industry the
accessibility and affordability of this
technology is limited
there is absolutely no reason other than
pure corrupt profit interest that every
single vehicle in the world cannot be
electric and utterly clean with zero
need for gasoline
as far as airplanes it is time we
realize that this means of travel is
inefficient cumbersome slow and causes
far too much pollution
this is a maglev train
it uses magnets for propulsion it is
fully suspended by a magnetic field and
requires less than two percent of the
energy used for plane travel the train
has no wheels so nothing can wear out
the current maximum speed of versions of
this technology as used in japan
is 361 miles per hour
however this version of the technology
is very dated
an organization called et3 which has
connections with the venus project has
established a tube based maglev that can
travel up to 4 000 miles per hour in a
motionless frictionless tube which can
go over land or underwater
imagine going from la to new york for an
extended lunch break or from washington
dc to beijing china in two hours
this is the future of continental and
intercontinental travel
fast clean with only a fraction of the
energy usage we use today for the same
means
in fact between maglev technology
advanced battery storage and geothermal
energy there would be no reason to ever
burn fossil fuels again
and we can do this now if we were not
held back by the paralyzing profit
structure
now america is inclined towards fascism
it has a propensity by its dominant
philosophy and religion to uphold the
fastest point of view
american ministry is essentially a
fastest institution if you don't
understand that the minute you punch
that time clock you walk into a
dictatorship we're given notions about
the
respectability of work
and um i really look at it as being paid
slavery
they're brought up to believe that you
shall earn your living by the sweat of
your brow that holds people back
freeing people
from drudgery repetitive jobs which make
them ignorant
you rob them
in our society that is a resource-based
economy
machines free people
you see we can't imagine that because
we've never known that kind of world
if we look back at history we see a very
clear pattern of machine automation
slowly replacing human labor
from the disappearance of the elevator
man
to the near full automation of an
automobile production plant the fact is
as technology grows the need for humans
in the workforce will continually be
diminished
this creates a serious clash which
proves the falseness of the
monetary-based labor system
for human employment is in direct
competition with technological
development
therefore given the fundamental priority
of profit by industry
people through time will be continually
laid off and replaced by machine
when industry takes on the machine
instead of shortening the workday they
downsize you lose your job so you have a
right to fear machines
in a high technology resource-based
economy it is conservative to say that
about 90 of all current occupations
could be phased out by machines freeing
humans to live their life without
servitude for this is the point of
technology itself
and through time with nanotechnology and
other highly advanced forms of science
it is not far-fetched to see how even
complex medical procedures could be
performed by machines as well
and based on the pattern with much
higher success rates than humans get
today
the path is clear but our monetary-based
structure which requires labor for
income blocks this progress for humans
need jobs in order to survive
the bottom line is that this system must
go or we will never be free and
technology will be constantly paralyzed
we have machines that clean out sewers
it frees a human being from doing that
so look at machines as extensions of
human performance
furthermore many occupations today will
have simply no basis to exist in a
resource-based economy such as anything
associated with the management of money
advertising along with the legal system
itself
for without money a great majority of
the crimes that are committed today
would never occur
virtually all forms of crime are a
consequence of the monetary system
either directly or by neuroses inflicted
through financial deprivation
therefore laws themselves could
eventually become extinct
instead of putting up a sign drive
carefully slippery when wet put abrasive
in the highway so it's not slippery went
wet and the person gets in the car that
drunk and the car oscillates a great
deal there's a little pendulum that
swings up and back and that'll pull the
car over the side not a law solution
puts sonar and radar and automobiles so
they can't hit one another man-made laws
are attempts to deal with occurring
problems and not knowing how to solve
them they make a law
in the united states the most privatized
capitalist country on the planet it
should come as no surprise that it also
has the largest prison population in the
world
growing every year
statistically most of these people are
uneducated and come from poor deprived
societies
and contrary to propaganda it is this
environmental conditioning which lures
them into criminal and violent behavior
however society looks the other way in
regard to this point
the legal and prison systems are just
more examples of how our society avoids
examining the root causes of behavior
billions are spent each year on prisons
and police while only a fraction is
spent on programs for poverty which is
one of the most fundamental variables
responsible for crime to begin with and
as long as we have an economic system
which prefers and in fact creates
scarcity and deprivation
crime will never go away
if people have access to the necessities
of life without servitude
debt
barter trade
they behave very differently you want
all these things available without a
price tag now then
you've got to have a price tag what'll
motivate people
a man gets everything he wants he just
lay around in the sun
this is a myth they perpetuate people in
our culture are trained to believe
that the monetary system produces
incentive if they have access to things
why should they want to do anything
they will lose their incentive that's
what you're taught
to support the monetary system when you
take money out of the scenario
there would be different
incentives very different incentives
when people have access to the
necessities of life their incentives
change what about the moon and the stars
new incentives arise
if you make a painting that you enjoy
you will enjoy giving it to other people
not selling it
i think most of the education that i've
seen today is essentially producing
a person for a job it's very specialized
they're not generalists people don't
know a lot about a lot of different
subjects i i don't think you could get
people to go to war
if if they knew a lot about a lot of
things i think education is mostly rote
and they're not taught how to solve
problems they're not given the tools
emotionally or within their own field of
how to do critical thinking
a resource-based economy the education
would be very different our society's
major concern
is mental development and to motivate
each person to their highest potential
because our philosophy is the smarter
people are the richer the world because
everybody becomes a contributor
the smarter
your kids are the better my life will be
because they'll be contributing more
constructively to the to the environment
and to my life because everything that
we devised within a resource-based
economy would be applied to society
there would be nothing to hold it back
patriotism
weapons armies navies all that is a sign
that we're not civilized yet
kids will ask their parents didn't you
see the necessity of the machines
dad couldn't you see that war was
inevitable when you produce scarcity
isn't it obvious of course the kid will
understand that you were pinheads raised
merely to serve the established
institutions with such an abominable
sick society that we won't make the
history book that you say that
large nations took land from smaller
nations used force and violence you'll
get history talked about as corrupt
behavior all the way along until the
beginning of the civilized world that's
when all the nations work together
world unification working toward common
good for all human beings
and without anyone being subservient to
anyone else
without social stratification whether it
be technical elitism or any other kind
of elitism
eradicated from the face of the earth
the state
does nothing because there is no state
there is no state
the system i advocate a resource-based
global economy is not perfect it's just
a lot better than what we have we can
never achieve perfection
[Music]
the social values of our society which
has manifested in perpetual warfare
corruption oppressive laws social
stratification irrelevant superstitions
environmental destruction and a despotic
socially indifferent profit-oriented
ruling class
is fundamentally the result of a
collective ignorance of two of the most
basic insights humans can have about
reality
the emergent and symbiotic aspects of
natural law
the emergent nature of reality is that
all systems whether it is knowledge
society technology philosophy or any
other creation
will when uninhibited undergo fluid
perpetual change
what we consider commonplace today such
as modern communication and
transportation
would have been unimaginable in ancient
times
likewise the future will contain
technologies realizations and social
structures that we cannot even fathom in
the present
we have gone from alchemy to chemistry
from a geocentric universe to a
heliocentric
from believing that demons were the
cause of illness to modern medicine
this development shows no sign of ending
and it is this awareness that aligns us
and leads us on a continuous path to
growth and progress
[Music]
static empirical knowledge does not
exist
rather it is the insight of the
emergence of all systems we must
recognize
this means we must be open to new
information at all times even if it
threatens our current belief system and
hence identities
sadly society today has failed to
recognize this and the established
institutions continue to paralyze growth
by preserving outdated social structures
simultaneously the population suffers
from a fear of change
for their conditioning assumes a static
identity and challenging one's belief
system usually results in insult and
apprehension
for being wrong is erroneously
associated with failure
when in fact to be proven wrong should
be celebrated for it is elevating
someone to a new level of understanding
furthering awareness
the fact is there is no such thing as a
smart human being
for it is merely a matter of time before
their ideas are updated changed or
eradicated
and this tendency to blindly hold on to
a belief system
sheltering it from new possibly
transforming information
is nothing less than a form of
intellectual materialism
the monetary system perpetuates this
materialism not only by its
self-preserving structures but also
through the countless number of people
who have been conditioned into blindly
and thoughtlessly upholding these
structures therefore becoming
self-appointed guardians of the status
quo
sheep which no longer need a sheepdog to
control them for they control each other
by ostracizing those who step out of the
norm
this tendency to resist change and
uphold existing institutions for the
sake of identity comfort power and
profit is completely unsustainable and
will only produce further imbalance
fragmentation distortion and invariably
destruction
[Music]
it's time to change
from hunters and gatherers to the
agricultural revolution to the
industrial revolution the pattern is
clear
it is time for a new social system which
reflects the understandings we have
today
the monetary system is a product of a
period of time where scarcity was a
reality
now with the age of technology it is no
longer relevant to society
gone with the aberrant behavior it
manifests
likewise dominant world views such as
theistic religion operate with the same
social irrelevancy
islam christianity judaism hinduism and
all of the others
exist as barriers to personal and social
growth
for each group perpetuates a closed
not
[Music]
available by instilling the
psychological distortion of faith upon
its followers where logic and new
information is rejected in favor of
traditionalized outdated beliefs
the concept of god is really a method of
accounting for the nature of things in
the early days people didn't know enough
about how things formed how nature
worked so they invented their own little
stories
and they made god
in their own image
a guy that gets angry
when people don't behave right he
creates floods and earthquakes
and they say it's an act of god
a cursory glance at the suppressed
history of religion reveals that even
the foundational myths themselves are
emergent culminations
developed through influence over time
for example a cardinal doctrine of the
christian faith is the death and
resurrection of christ
this notion is so important that the
bible itself states
and if christ be not risen then is our
preaching vain and your faith is also
vader
yet it is very difficult to take this
account literally for not only is there
no primary source denoting the
supernatural event in secular history
awareness of the enormous number of
pre-christian saviors who also died and
were resurrected immediately puts the
story in mythological territory by
association
early church figures such as tertullian
went to great lengths to break these
associations even claiming that the
devil caused the similarities to occur
stating in the second century the devil
whose business is to pervert the truth
mimics the exact circumstance of the
divine sacraments he baptizes his
believers and promises forgiveness of
sins he celebrates the ablation of bread
and brings in the symbol of the
resurrection
let us therefore acknowledge the
craftiness of the devil who copied
certain things of those that be divine
is truly sad however is that when we
cease the idea that the stories from
christianity judaism islam and all the
others
are literal history
and accept them for what they really are
which are purely allegorical expressions
derived from many faiths
we see that all religions share a common
thread
and it is this unifying imperative that
needs to be recognized and appreciated
religious belief has caused more
fragmentation and conflict than any
other ideology
christianity alone has 34 000 different
subgroups
the bible is subject to interpretation
when you read it you say
i think jesus meant this i think job
meant that oh no he meant this so you
have to lose in the seventh-day
adventist the catholic
and a church divided is no church at all
and a church divided is no church at all
and this point on division which is a
trademark of all theistic religions
brings us to our second failure of
awareness
the false assumption of separation
through the rejection of the symbiotic
relationship of life
apart from the understanding that all
natural systems are emergent where all
notions of reality will be constantly
developed altered and even eradicated
we must also understand that all systems
are in fact invented fragments
merely for the sake of conversation
for there is no such thing as
independence in nature
the whole of nature is a unified system
of interdependent variables
each a cause and a reaction
existing only as a concentrated hole
you don't see the plug connected to the
environment so it looks like we're free
wandering around take the oxygen away we
all die immediately take plant life away
we die and without the sun all the
plants die so we are connected
we really must take into account the
totality this isn't just a human
experience on this planet this is a
total experience and we know we can't
survive without plants and animals we
know we can't survive without the four
elements you know and so
when are we going to really start taking
that into account
that's what it is to be successful
success depends on how well we relate to
everything around us
i'm very aware of the fact that my
grandson cannot possibly hope
to inherit a sustainable peaceful stable
socially just world unless every child
today growing up in ethiopia in
indonesia in bolivia in palestine and
israel also has that same expectation
you've got to take care of the whole
community
or you're going to have serious problems
and now we have to see that the whole
world is the community
and we must all take care of each other
that way
and it's not just a community of human
beings it's a community of plants and
animals and elements and we really need
to understand that that's what's going
to bring us joy to and pleasure that's
what's missing in our lives right now we
can call it spirituality but the fact of
the matter is joy comes from that bliss
of connectedness that's our god spirit
that's that side of ourselves that
really feels it and you can feel it deep
inside you it's this amazing wonderful
feeling and you know it when you get it
you don't get it from money
i get it from connection
now if that isn't a hazard to this
country
how are we gonna keep building nuclear
weapons you know what i mean
what's gonna happen to the arms industry
when we realize we're all one
it's gonna [ __ ] up the economy
the economy that's fake anyway an
economy that's fake anyway the economy
that's fake anyway the economy that's
fake anyway the economy that's fake
anyway
which would be a real bummer
you can see why the government's
cracking down
on the idea of experiencing
unconditional love
once we understand that the integrity of
our personal existences are completely
dependent on the integrity of everything
else in our world we have truly
understood the meaning of unconditional
love
for love is extensionality and seeing
everything as you and you as everything
can have no conditionalities
for in fact we are all everything at
once
if it's true that we're all from the
center of a star every atom in each of
us from the center of a star then we're
all the same thing even a coke machine
or a cigarette butt in the street in
buffalo is made out of atoms that came
from a star they've all been recycled
thousands of times as have you and i and
therefore it's only me out there
so what is there to be afraid of what is
there that needs solace seeking nothing
there's nothing to be afraid of because
it's all us the trouble is we have been
separated by being born and given a name
and an identity and being individuated
we've been separated from the oneness
and that's what religion exploits that
people have this yearning to be part of
the overall one again so they exploit
that they call it god they say he has
rules
and i think it's cruel
i think you can do it absent religion
[Music]
it's time to claim the unity our
outmoded social systems have broken
apart
and worked together to create a
sustainable global society where
everyone is taken care of and everyone
is truly free
your personal beliefs whatever they may
be are meaningless when it comes to the
necessities of life every human being is
born naked needed warmth food water
shelter
everything else is auxiliary
therefore the most important issue at
hand is the intelligent management of
the earth's resources
this can never be accomplished in a
monetary system for the pursuit of
profit is the pursuit of self-interest
and therefore imbalance is inherent
politicians are useless
for our true problems in life are
technical not political
furthermore ideologies that separate
humanity such as religion need strong
reflection in the community
in regard to its value purpose and
social relevancy
hopefully through time religion will
lose its materialism and basis in
superstition and move into the useful
field of philosophy
the fact is society today is backwards
with politicians constantly talking
about protection and security rather
than creation unity and progress
the us alone now spends about 500
billion dollars annually on defense
that is enough to send every high school
senior in america to a four-year college
in the 1940s the manhattan project
produced the first true weapon of mass
destruction
this program employed 130 000 people
at an extreme financial cost
imagine what our life would be like
today if that group of scientists
instead of working on a way of killing
people
worked on a way to create a
self-sustaining abundant world
life today would be very very different
if that was their goal
instead of weapons of mass destruction
it is time to unleash something much
more powerful
weapons of mass creation
our true divinity is in our ability to
create and armed with the understanding
of the symbiotic connections of life
while being guided by the emergent
nature of reality there is nothing we
cannot do or accomplish
of course we face strong barriers in the
form of established power structures
that refuse to change
at the heart of these structures is the
monetary system as explained earlier the
fractional reserve policy is a form of
slavery through debt where it is
literally impossible for society to be
free
in turn free market capitalism in the
form of free trade uses debt to imprison
the world and manipulate countries into
subservience to a handful of large
business and political powers
apart from these obvious immoralities
the system itself is based on
competition which immediately destroys
the possibility of large-scale
collaborations for the common good hence
paralyzing any attempt at true global
sustainability
these financial and corporate structures
are now obsolete and they must be
outgrown
of course we cannot be naive enough to
think that the business and financial
leader are going to subscribe to this
idea for they will lose power and
control therefore peaceful yet highly
strategic action must be taken
the most powerful course of action is
simple
we have to alter our behavior to force
the power structure to the will of the
people
we must stop supporting the system
the only way the establishment will
change is by our refusal to participate
while continuously acknowledging its
endless flaws and corruptions
they're not going to give up the
monetary system because of
our designs are what we recommend the
system has to fail and people have to
lose confidence in their elected leaders
that will be a major turning point if
the venus project is offered as a
possible alternative if not i fear the
consequences the trends now
that our country is going bankrupt the
probability is
our country moves toward a military
dictatorship to prevent riots
and complete social breakdown once the
us breaks down all the other cultures
will undergo similar things
as of now the world financial system is
on the brink of collapse due to its own
shortcomings the comptroller of currency
stated in 2003 that the interest on the
us national debt will not be affordable
in less than 10 years
this theoretically means total
bankruptcy for the u.s economy and its
implications for the world are immense
in turn the fractional reserve-based
monetary system is reaching its
theoretical limits of expansion and the
banking failures you are seeing are just
the beginning
this is why inflation is skyrocketing
all debt is at record levels and the
government and fed are hemorrhaging new
money to bail out the corrupt system
for the only way to keep the banks going
is by making more money the only way to
make more money is to create more debt
and inflation it is simply a matter of
time before the tables turn and there
was no one willing to take new loans
while defaults grow as people are unable
to afford their current loans
then the expansion of money will stop
and contraction will begin on a scale
never before seen ending a century-long
pyramid scheme
this has already begun
therefore we need to expose this
financial failure for what it is using
this weakness to our advantage
here are some suggestions
expose the banking fraud
citibank jpmorgan chase and bank of
america are the most powerful
controllers within the corrupt federal
reserve system
it's time to boycott these institutions
if you have a bank account or a credit
card with any of them move your money to
another bank
if you have a mortgage refinance with
another bank if you own their stock sell
it if you work for them quit
this gesture will express contempt for
the true powers behind the private
banking cartel known as the federal
reserve and create awareness about the
fraud of the banking system itself
two turn off the tv news visit the
emerging independent news agencies on
the internet for your information
cnn nbc abc fox and all the others
present all news pre-filtered to
maintain the status quo with four
corporations owning all major media
outlets objective information is
impossible this is the true beauty of
the internet and the establishment has
been losing control because of this free
flow of information
we must protect the internet at all
times as it is truly our savior right
now
three
don't ever
allow yourself your family or anyone you
know
to ever
join the military
this is an obsolete institution now used
exclusively for maintaining an
establishment that is no longer relevant
u.s soldiers in iraq work for u.s
corporations not the people propaganda
forces us to believe that war is natural
and the military is an honorable
institution
well if war is natural why are there 18
suicides every single day by american
veterans who have post-traumatic stress
disorder
if our military men and women are so
honored why is it that 25 of the
american homeless population are
veterans
four
stop supporting the energy companies if
you live in a detached house get off the
grid investigate every means of making
your home self-sustainable with clean
energy
solar wind and other renewable energies
are now affordable consumer realities
and considering the never-ending rising
cost of traditional energies it will
likely be a cheaper investment over time
if you drive get the smallest car you
can and consider using one of the many
conversion technologies that can enable
your car to be a hybrid electric or run
on anything other than establishment
fuels
five reject the political system
the illusion of democracy is an insult
to our intelligence in a monetary system
there is no such thing as a true
democracy and there never was
we have two political parties owned by
the same set of corporate lobbyists
they are placed in their positions by
the corporations with popularity
artificially projected by their media
in a system of inherent corruption the
change of personnel every couple of
years has very little relevance
instead of pretending that the political
game has any true meaning focus your
energy on how to transcend this failed
system
and six
join the movement
go to the
zeitgeistmovement.com and help us create
the largest mass movement for social
change the world has ever seen
we must mobilize and educate everyone
about the inherent corruption of our
current world system
along with the only true sustainable
solution
declaring all the natural resources on
the planet as common heritage to all
people
while informing everyone as to the true
state of technology and how we can all
be free if the world works together
rather than fights
the choice lies with you you can
continue to be a slave to the financial
system and watch the continuous wars
depressions and injustice across the
globe while placating yourself with vain
entertainment and materialistic garbage
or you can focus your energy on true
meaningful lasting holistic change which
actually has the realistic ability to
support and free all humans with no one
left behind
but in the end the most relevant change
must occur first inside of you
the real revolution is the revolution of
consciousness
and each one of us first needs to
eliminate the divisionary materialistic
noise we have been conditioned to think
is true
while discovering amplifying and
aligning with the signal
coming from our true
empirical oneness
it is up to you
what we are trying
in all these discussions and talks here
is to see if we cannot radically bring
about a transformation of the mind
not accept things as they are
but to understand it to go into it to
examine it give your heart and your mind
with everything that you have to find
out a way of living differently
but
that depends on you or not somebody else
because in this there is no teacher no
people
there's no leader
there's no guru
there's no master no savior you yourself
are the teacher and the people you're
the master you are the guru you are the
leader
you are everything
and
to understand
is to transform what is
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you